hey there space explorers today you and
the peanuts gang will take on three
exciting stem missions inspired by
snoopy in space
collecting space samples building a
stellar satellite and crafting moon sand
i can't go to space i don't have my
toothbrush feel free to attempt all of
them or just your favorite it's up to
you and your team so gather the parts
you'll need grab a grown-up to help and
get ready to blast off are we ready to
launch ready
[Music]
mission one
galaxy slime
the galaxy is pretty big
[Music]
first gather your materials
a half cup of clear glue a half cup of
water a half cup of liquid cornstarch
food coloring glitter and confetti stars
and a large bowl and spoon to mix it all
together
[Music]
first mix the water and glue in your
bowl
[Music]
next
add a drop or two of your favorite food
coloring
and plenty of glitter and stars
[Music]
now
add the liquid cornstarch
and stir until there's no liquid left
your bowl should now be totally full of
galaxy slime
start experimenting with your galaxy
slime by kneading and playing with it
you should notice the slime feeling
different the more you play with it
how far can you stretch it i can't wait
to see what discoveries they've made
like all the aliens they're hiding in
the basement
good grief
[Music]
our next mission is pre-flight satellite
now i'm hoping to get a transmission
from even farther in space
here's what you'll need a juice box some
sponges a few pipe cleaners a pickup
stick a paper straw a styrofoam ball
black construction paper washers and
bolts tape and finally scissors
so what do we do now let's start
building
first wrap the juice box in your
favorite colorful paper
a juice box makes a great container for
all your scientific instruments
[Music]
in this section we're going to be
working with safety scissors so grab an
adult and have them cut the sponges into
three pieces
[Music]
the sponges will make perfect solar
panels to soak up sunlight
now run the pipe cleaners through each
sponge
and then into the juice box
if you need help making holes in the
juice box ask an adult
[Music]
tilt the sponges or your satellite's
panels to capture maximum sunlight power
now it's time to assemble your
communications by having an adult cut
the styrofoam ball in half and they can
also cut a small circle of black
construction paper for you
and glue it to the flat surface of the
foam
[Music]
then take a small part of the straw and
stick it through the black paper into
the foam
creating a communication dish
grab a pickup stick and push one end
into the foam
[Music]
and the other into the top of the juice
box
[Music]
now your satellite can stay in contact
with ground control snoopy do you copy
to make sure your satellite doesn't get
lost it'll need an orientation tracker
to keep an eye on the stars
your washers will be the perfect
trackers once you tape them to the box
time to launch and drift through space
[Music]
our final mission is critical crater
creator
[Music]
here's what you'll need to create some
moonsand craters two and a half cups of
colorful sand glitter one and a half
cups of cornstarch three-quarter cup of
canola oil and a large mixing bowl and
spoon what are we waiting for
okay step one pour all of your sand into
a bowl
we're combining blue and black sand but
use any colors you like and mix it up
step 2 slowly add in the cornstarch one
or two spoonfuls at a time
[Music]
step 3 slowly pour in the canola oil
and step 4 is the most fun add glitter
and mix it all together
[Applause]
next grab an adult and transfer your
moonsand to a new container if you'd
like
add craters mountains canyons
and colorful decorations
it never hurts to add more glitter too
now you and your team have your very own
moonscape to explore
great job today
[Music]
great work everyone now you have all the
tools to make any mission a success
i'm swept up in the moment all that's
left is to get out and explore the solar
system is a fast and wondrous place
snoopy in space the search for life